Just a warning, this episode contains mature language. I remember the first day I got to college. I was in line at some bakery in the town. It's a woman pulled me out and said, I just want to talk to you because I'm a Christian woman and I worry about people like you and your relationship with Satan. My boss, Roman Mars, what were you wearing that day? I was, I think it was, I must have been a band T-shirt and a flannel or something.
先提醒一下，本集包含粗俗语言。我记得上大学的第一天，我在镇上一家面包店排队。一个女人把我拉过去说：“我只是想跟你谈谈，因为我是个基督徒，我很担心像你这样的人以及你与撒旦的关系。”我的老板罗曼·马尔斯，你那天穿的是什么？我想，我当时穿的应该是一件乐队T恤和法兰绒衬衫之类的东西。
I was nothing. Like a band T- shirt, one particular shirt. So if you met me from the age of 5th, 14 to 19, I was probably wearing this one who's gonna do t-shirt. That by the time I stopped wearing it, you know, went from basically white to gray to almost kind of clear. Yeah.
我基本上什么都没穿。就像乐队T恤，某一件特定的衬衫。所以如果你在14到19岁之间认识我，我可能一直穿着这件谁都知道的T恤。到我不穿它的时候，你知道，它基本上从白色变成灰色，又几乎变得有点透明了。是的。
Oh, I'm so close. Oh, so. And so to keep it all together, I put little safety pins across the top to keep it to keep it all together. So is that because you saw other people doing that? No, so I remember in high school, there was, there was very little punk presence. You would call this skater if you wore weird clothes or listen to the bands I listened to. This is going to sound so weird.
哦，太像了。哦，太……为了把它固定好，我在领口别了几个小别针，把它们固定在一起。是因为你看到别人也这么做吗？不，我记得在高中时，朋克的身影非常少。如果你穿奇装异服或者听我听的那些乐队，别人会叫你滑板爱好者。这听起来太奇怪了。
This quizzical look on your face. It's just but in Central Ohio, in the late 80s, there wasn't a concept of what a hardcore punk was. There was no, I always call a skater and rocks were thrown at me. You know, I'd never run a skateboard before. People threw rocks at you. Oh shit. Yeah. This is different. Sharks. Yeah. Skaters were hated by everybody. So why bother to stand out, especially if people are like actively throwing rocks at you, like why bother? Yeah. It's weird because I don't know. I don't know why I want to have that fight all the time, but I had to.
你脸上带着这种困惑的表情。只是，在80年代末的俄亥俄州中部，人们根本没有硬核朋克的概念。没有，我总是被称为滑板爱好者，而且有人朝我扔石头。你知道的，我以前从来没玩过滑板。人们朝你扔石头？哦，天哪。是的。这太不一样了。鲨鱼。是的。滑板爱好者遭到所有人的憎恨。那为什么还要特立独行，尤其是当人们积极地朝你扔石头时，为什么还要费劲？是的。这很奇怪，因为我不知道。我不知道为什么我总是想去抗争，但我不得不这么做。
Articles of interest. A show about what we wear. And so maybe the idea is about clothes. You can attach ideas about clothes. An idea of home to a piece of cloth. These are glass for a market, cloth. These are special items. I'm not a kid. Any fork and wear clothes, but if you haven't got the attitude and style to carry it off,
《感兴趣的物件》。一个关于我们穿什么的节目。所以，也许这个概念是关于服装的。你可以将关于服装的想法附加在上面。将家的概念附加在一块布料上。这些都是市场的玻璃，布料。这些都是特殊的物品。我可不是小孩子。任何人都可以穿衣服，但如果你没有那种气场和风格来驾驭它，
then you're just the closed walls. There's this myth that it's frivolous or unproductive to care about how you look. Clothing and fashion get trivialized a lot. But think about who culturally gets associated with clothing and fashion. Young people, women, queers, and people of color. Groups of people who historically haven't been listened to
那你不过是衣服的架子。有一种神话认为，关心自己的外表是轻浮的或没有生产力的。服装和时尚经常被严重轻视。但想想在文化上，谁会与服装和时尚联系在一起？年轻人、女性、酷儿和有色人种。历史上一直未被倾听的群体，
have expressed themselves on their bodies through their style, their hair, their tattoos, their piercings, and what they wear. You got to understand, black working class kid, that's all the only way we had to express ourselves with through the music we listened to and the clothes we wore. This is Don Letz, a legendary DJ and filmmaker and creator of the documentary, Punk Attitude. I've always engaged with the look, know in black culture we've been forced to express ourselves in a very punk rock way and what is a very white world we've only been left
通过他们的风格、发型、纹身、穿孔以及他们穿的衣服，在自己的身体上表达了自我。你得明白，作为一个黑人工人阶级小孩，那是我们表达自我的唯一方式，就是通过我们听的音乐和穿的衣服。这是唐·莱茨，一位传奇DJ、电影制作人，也是纪录片《朋克态度》的创作者。我一直对这种外表感兴趣，你知道在黑人文化中，我们被迫以非常朋克摇滚的方式表达自己，在一个非常白人的世界里，我们只能在边缘地带活动，
the fringes to operate within to understand so that's forced us to do weird things like come up with reggae for instance which is actually formed by a lack of technology not because you've got it you know the minutes or a definition of punk hip hop to turntables and a microphone. I mean, if that ain't a form of black punk rock, what is? Punk rock, in the classic sense, in the way it sounds, in the way it looks, emerged from a place of disenchantment and dissolution.
这就迫使我们做一些奇怪的事情，比如发明了雷鬼音乐，这实际上是由于缺乏技术造成的，而不是因为你拥有它，你知道的，或者说朋克、嘻哈的定义就是两个唱片机和一个麦克风。我的意思是，如果这还算不上黑人朋克摇滚的一种形式，那什么才是？传统意义上的朋克摇滚，从它的声音和外观来看，都源于一种幻灭感和瓦解感。
I already was pretty alienated being black, but by the mid-70s, it's interesting, because society had managed to alienate own white youth. For talking specifically London society. You've got to set the scene a little bit. You know, we're doing that mid-70s. The times were tough. We were talking about more social crisis, economic, political.
作为一个黑人，我本来就已经相当疏离了，但到了70年代中期，有趣的是，社会已经成功地让白人青年也感到疏离。我们特指伦敦社会。你得稍微铺垫一下场景。你知道，我们在说70年代中期。那个时期很艰难。我们谈论的是更多的社会危机、经济危机、政治危机。
You can't find jobs, accommodation. The housing problem of course is terrific. And financial, you know, we're doing about three-day weeks. We're very concerned about unemployment. With no room, with no job. Power cuts and strikes, and all this of massive unemployment. We do not have sufficient houses, jobs and schools for our own people, let alone immigrants. There are far too many immigrants in this country.
你找不到工作、住处。住房问题当然非常严重。还有经济问题，你知道的，我们在实行三日工作制。我们非常关心失业问题。没有房间，没有工作。断电、罢工，以及所有这些大规模的失业。我们没有足够的房屋、工作和学校来满足我们自己人民的需要，更不用说移民了。这个国家的移民实在太多了。
The rise in the national front. We can't go into the locals anymore. They're full of with noisy foreigners, and we don't like it. We don't like it. We like it. Oh, no, no, whatever, it's widely agreed that punk music came from somewhere in the United States. Everybody thinks England invented punk. Rubbish, but they were smart enough to give it a look.
国民阵线的崛起。我们再也不能去当地的酒吧了。里面挤满了吵闹的外国人，我们不喜欢这样。我们不喜欢。我们喜欢。哦，不，无论如何，人们普遍认为朋克音乐起源于美国的某个地方。每个人都认为英国发明了朋克。胡说八道，但他们足够聪明，给它设计了外表。
The look of punk. That started in London. It wasn't invented here. They just gave it a style, which is not to be sniffed out. Because that music and style combination is a deadly combination. And the look of punk, like traditional 70s British punk, is so iconic. Think the green mohawk, the safety pins, the leather jacket, the plaid mini skirt. And look that iconic. That specific.
朋克的造型。那是从伦敦开始的。它不是在这里发明的。他们只是赋予了它一种风格，这是不容忽视的。因为音乐与风格的结合是一种致命的组合。朋克的外观，比如传统的70年代英国朋克，太具标志性了。想想绿色的莫霍克发型、安全别针、皮夹克、格子迷你裙。如此标志性的造型。如此具体。
It doesn't just happen by accident. Someone designed it. Hi, are you open? Yeah, thanks. On 430 Kings Road in London, there is a little shop. It looks like a little shack, it's tiny. Don Letz remembers the first time he went in there. I found myself wandering up and down the King's Road Chelsea, which back in the
这绝不是偶然发生的。有人设计了它。嗨，你们开门吗？好的，谢谢。在伦敦国王路430号，有一家小店。它看起来像个小棚子，非常小。唐·莱茨还记得他第一次进去的情景。我发现自己漫步在伦敦切尔西的国王路上，在那个年代，
day in the early 70s, which was like the major fashion high street in the UK in London. And I wandered into this store called, it was either called Too Fast to Live Too Young to Die or Let It Rock, because He kept changing the name of the store. And I walked into what was kind of a laddins cave of subculture. And Malcolm was there and Vivian was there. Vivian Westwood and Malcolm McLaren, the couple that owned the shop in the 70s. They had started out selling records and then moved into clothing. But I struck up a relationship with these guys and it was probably one of the
也就是70年代初，这里是英国伦敦主要的时尚商业街。我走进了这家名为“生而太快，死而太年轻”或“让它摇滚”的店铺，因为他不断更改店名。我走进了这个充满亚文化的宝库。马尔科姆在那里，维薇安也在那里。维薇安·韦斯特伍德和马尔科姆·麦克拉伦，70年代这家店的老板夫妇。他们最初靠卖唱片起家，后来转行做服装。但我与这些人建立了联系，这可能是我经历过的最巧合、最幸运的会面之一。
most fort two-at-a-tus meetings I've ever had. Vivian Westwood was in her early 30s, a primary schoolteacher and mother of two who sowed all the clothes in her living room. She had no formal training, but she had grown up sowing her own clothes out of necessity. Malcolm McLaren was in his mid-20s and lived in this kind of world of ideas. The countercultural riot in 68 Paris, Grovener Square, you know Kent State, all that stuff. Those are the situationists movement in France. This stuff I would never fucking heard about. The situationists were really important to Vivian and Malcolm.
维薇安·韦斯特伍德当时三十岁出头，是一名小学老师和两个孩子的母亲，她所有的衣服都是在客厅里缝制的。她没有受过正规培训，但由于生计所需，她从小就自己缝制衣服。马尔科姆·麦克拉伦当时二十岁出头，生活在一种理念世界中。68年巴黎的反文化骚乱、格罗夫纳广场、肯特州立大学，所有这些。那是法国的激进情境主义运动。这些东西我他妈的从来没听说过。情境主义对维薇安和马尔科姆来说非常重要。
As early as the 1950s, situationists theorist declared that artists and thinkers were morally obligated to break down the divides between art and life. To fuse art with everyday existence, so that art could not be cleaved away and etharized and put into galleries and academies. And the way to do this, the situation is said. To fuse art and life is for artists and activists to be provocateurs, to create dramatic, outlandish interruptions on the everyday, to expose the absurdity of the status quo. Art and protest were to be on the streets with no barriers for everyone in their faces.
早在20世纪50年代，情境主义理论家就宣称，艺术家和思想家有道德义务打破艺术与生活之间的界限。将艺术与日常生活融合在一起，这样艺术就不会被剥离、被束缚并放进画廊和学院里。而实现这一目标的途径，情境主义者说，就是让艺术家和活动家成为煽动者，在日常生活中制造戏剧性的、离奇的干涉，以揭露现状的荒谬性。艺术和抗议应该出现在街头，没有障碍，直接面对每一个人，
Whether they wanted it or not. Yeah, the whole idea of being subversive, thinking out of the box, being punk. But the look of punk still wasn't quite born yet. In their pursuit of testing limits, of merging art and life, Vivian Westwood and Malcolm McLaren were constantly changing the shop, and the
不管他们愿不愿意。是的，颠覆、打破常规、做朋克的整个理念。但朋克的造型当时还没有真正诞生。在不断测试极限、将艺术与生活融合的追求中，维薇安·韦斯特伍德和马尔科姆·麦克拉伦不断改变着店铺以及，
style of clothing sold within it. They'd close it down, rename it and reopen it again. And it's not like they were closing the stores down because they were failures. They were changing the face of 430 Kings Road because they wanted to. Malcolm McLaren got bored, and he wanted to move on, and so did Vivian. This is Claire Wilcox, senior curator at the Victoria and Albert Museum. By the way, Vivien Westwood herself declined to be a part of this story. But Claire Wilcox has interviewed Westwood and curated an incredible exhibit of the many
其中销售的服装风格。他们会关闭店铺，改名后重新开张。并不是说他们因为店铺经营失败而关门。他们改变国王路430号的面貌是因为他们想这么做。马尔科姆·麦克拉伦厌倦了，他想继续前进，维薇安也是。这是维多利亚和阿尔伯特博物馆的高级策展人克莱尔·威尔科克斯。顺便说一句，维薇安·韦斯特伍德本人拒绝参与这个故事。但克莱尔·威尔科克斯采访过韦斯特伍德，并策划了一个令人难以置信的展览，展示了她作品的许多，
phases of her work. A society of always outrunning their audiences, they always one step ahead. They never rested on their laurels, They kept moving, changing, gathering momentum. They were kind of like anthropologists. They get really intrigued by a certain subculture and they build the shop around it. 430 Kings Road had an iteration where it sold dandy rocker clothes
不同阶段。一个总是超越其受众的社会，他们总是领先一步。他们从不居功自傲，不断前进，不断改变，积蓄势头。他们有点像人类学家。他们对某个特定的亚文化非常着迷，然后围绕它建立一家店。国王路430号曾有一段时期出售花花公子摇滚风格的服装，
and another making more leather, biker-inspired stuff. And then in 1974, Vivian and Malcolm turned 430 Kings Road into a shop called Sex. It was called Sex. One word, all caps. What Vivian said about being interested and closing used in the sex industry. The late text, the rubber, was that she appreciated it for its strength, kind of beauty. The sign just said Sex in big pink plush letters.
另一时期则制作更多皮革和机车风格的服装。然后在1974年，维薇安和马尔科姆将国王路430号变成了一家名为“性”（Sex）的店。它就叫“性”。一个词，全大写。维薇安对情趣和性产业中的服装感兴趣时曾说，她欣赏紧身衣和橡胶制品的强度和某种美感。招牌上只有用巨大的粉红色毛绒字母写成的“性”字。
The clothes inside were leather and rubber and covered with straps, skin tight and endrogenous. And she said that you had a mixed cloned tail coming to the shop when it was called sex range from as she's had people with a perverse interest in these types of garments. And then kids off the street just wanting to be fashionable. So it was a sort of hybrid moment.
里面的衣服都是皮革和橡胶材质的，上面挂满了带子，紧身且雌雄莫辨。她说，当这家店叫“性”的时候，光顾的顾客群体各种各样，从她所说的那种对这类服装有变态兴趣的人，到只想赶时髦的街头少年。所以这是一个某种意义上的混合时期。
Malcolm Invivian knew how to shock. No one had stuff like theirs. No, in the mohair tops and some of the t-shirts. It's fucking cool. I nearly died trying to put on a rubber t-shirt once. Seriously, that's not a joke. I didn't put the towel-compiled thing on. Nobody told me me about that shit and nearly died with this thing wrapped around my neck trying to get it off. On trips to New York, Malcolm and Vivian discovered the burgeoning American punk music scene,
马尔科姆和维薇安深谙如何制造震撼。没有人拥有像他们那样的东西。不，马海毛上衣和一些T恤。真是酷毙了。我有一次为了穿上一件橡胶T恤差点死掉。真的，这不是开玩笑的。我没有在里面抹滑石粉。没有人跟我说过这破事，差点被缠在脖子上的这东西勒死，好不容易才脱下来。在去纽约的旅行中，马尔科姆和维薇安发现了正在萌芽的美国朋克音乐场景，
which was blooming in interesting new ways. And so, upon his return to London, Malcolm decided that he would like to manage a band of his very own. He and Vivian gathered some kids who worked at and hung out around 430 Kings Road and formed them into a group, named the Sex Pistols. But it's not like the Sex Pistols were just like a clever roost to sell clothes. No, I mean, listen, it was a fortuitous combination for those things to work together. But that wasn't anything weird. I mean, the style of music in this country is just like it's so important. So I don't think that there was any shame in that.
它正以有趣的新方式蓬勃发展。因此，马尔科姆回到伦敦后，决定自己也想管理一支乐队。他和维薇安召集了一些在国王路430号工作和闲逛的孩子，把他们组成了一个乐队，名叫“性手枪”（Sex Pistols）。但这并不是说“性手枪”只是一个卖衣服的聪明的噱头。不，我的意思是，听着，让这些东西共同起作用是一个幸运的组合。但这并不是什么奇怪的事。我的意思是，这个国家的音乐风格就是如此重要。所以我认为这没什么好羞耻的。
Malcolm Invivian wrote some of the lyrics for the Sex Pistols, which were about, you know, NRK in the UK and bad mouthing the Queen. It was not your mother's rock and roll. It was the anti band,, the anti-music built to shock kind of for politics, but also kind of just to shock people like a situation is happening. Although maybe that's giving Malcolm too much credit. I don't know how planned out this was. Malcolm wanted to create Malcolm world.
马尔科姆和维薇安为“性手枪”写了一些歌词，内容是关于英国的无政府状态和对女王的辱骂。这不是你妈妈听的摇滚乐。这是反乐队、反音乐，专为制造震撼而生，有点是为了政治，但也有点只是为了像情境主义发生那样去震撼人们。尽管这也许是对马尔科姆过于赞誉了。我不知道这一切计划得有多周密。马尔科姆只想创造一个马尔科姆的世界。
What is endgame was I have no fucking idea. I think Malcolm did, to be honest, he did make up a lot of shit as he went along and a lot of things that kind of ended up in chaos. He pretended that he orchestrated, but that's okay. What was your question? This new movement demanded a new look, a new store. So in 1977, 430 Kings Road was reincarnated again. This time, it was called Seditionaries. And this is the iteration of the store in which punk fashion would truly emerge. In a way, Seditionaries was a line in the sand because here you had the true emerging of music and fashion, the occurrence, two main labs. The chapters of 430 Kings Road all compounded on each other.
他的最终目的是什么，我他妈的毫无头脑。说实话，我觉得马尔科姆在摸索前进的过程中确实编造了很多鬼话，很多事情最终都陷入了混乱。他假装这一切都是他精心策划的，但没关系。你的问题是什么？这个新运动需要新的外表、新的店铺。所以在1977年，国王路430号再次转世。这一次，它被称为“煽动者”（Seditionaries）。这就是朋克时尚真正诞生的那家店。从某种意义上说，“Seditionaries”划清了界限，因为在这里，音乐和时尚真正地融合在了一起，这是两个主要的实验室。国王路430号的各个篇章相互交织。
Elements of Edwardian Dandy and rocker and biker and sex worker all combined and catalyzed with hard, fast music and political imagery. It's a ripped up union jacked, held together with saved to pins. This is Style icon Michael Kostiff, a long time neighbor of 430 Kings Road. Over the years, Michael and his wife, Galinda, bought so many Westwood clothes, their collection was acquired by the Victoria and Albert Museum. Yeah, and they're sort of set. They've got a big wide belt. They're a little bit hipster almost. Michael is showing me a pair of his old bondage trousers, which look like a straight jacket for your legs.
爱德华时代花花公子、摇滚乐手、机车骑手和性工作者的元素与强劲、快节奏的音乐以及政治意象相结合并催化。这是一面被撕碎的英国国旗，用安全别针固定在一起。这是时尚偶像迈克尔·科斯蒂夫，国王路430号的多年邻居。多年来，迈克尔和他的妻子加林达买下了如此多的韦斯特伍德服装，他们的收藏被维多利亚和阿尔伯特博物馆收购了。是的，他们那种套装。他们有一条很宽的腰带。它们几乎有点嬉皮士风格。迈克尔正在向我展示他的一条旧捆绑裤（bondage trousers），它看起来就像是为双腿准备的束缚衣。
They're loaded down with zippers and chains and straps hanging off them. And there's even a strap that ties your knees together, which Michael assures me was less limiting than you'd think. The legs are connected with the strap. Yeah, yeah, so he's strapped them through. yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah and some had killed so that you could clip on the front and back or little towels and other things that would hang off them. The last time I had a conversation with Bob Marley, we had an argument about the bodied trousers that I was wearing. What, what did you say about them?
上面挂满了拉链、链条和带子。甚至还有一条把你的双腿绑在一起的带子，迈克尔向我保证，这比想象中受到的限制要小。裤腿是用带子连在一起的。是的，是的，所以他把它们绑穿过去。是的，是的，是的，是的，有些还带有夹子，你可以把前后片或小毛巾以及其他会挂在上面的东西夹在上面。我上次和鲍勃·马利交谈时，我们还为了我穿的这条捆绑裤争论过。什么，他关于这个说什么了？
He didn't like them. He thought they looked like mountaineer trousers. Vivian's clothes turned people into strange sculptures. She played with the human form, binding the legs together or extending sleeves down to the floor and pushing the body into new angles. All the things were sort of cut differently, you know, with one sleeve higher than with a neck hold to one side and it sort of pulled the fabric in different ways. It was all rather fabulous. As a sartorial movement, it was resolved. It was well crafted.
他不喜欢。他觉得它们看起来像登山裤。维薇安的服装把人变成奇特的雕塑。她玩弄人体形态，将双腿绑在一起，或者将衣袖一直延伸到地板，将身体推向新的角度。所有的衣服裁剪方式都很独特，你知道的，一只袖子比另一只高，领口偏向一侧，这以不同的方式拉扯着面料。这一切都相当了不起。作为一场服装运动，它是坚定不移的。它做工精良。
It was not cheap. It wasn't cheap. it wasn't cheap. Ah, the clothes were not cheap. In other words, fucking expensive. But it was clothes as art though, without a doubt. Those first punk clothes weren't dirty grungy sloppy. They were fabulous and strange.
它不便宜。它不便宜。它不便宜。啊，这些衣服可不便宜。换句话说，贵得要命。但毫无疑问，这就是作为艺术的服装。那些最早的朋克服装可一点也不脏乱差、邋里邋遢。它们华丽而奇特。
I mean, the thing about Vivian's clothes is they were clothes as arts. You got to understand that. Vivian has always taken great pride in crafting her clothes very carefully. You get this extraordinary sort of marriage of craft and care and you know, downright outrageousness. So outrageous that other shop started to copy Vivian's designs. Lots of people copied those looks. Once the junior was out of the bottle, then the whole of King's Road
我的意思是，薇薇安的衣服之所以独特，是因为它们本身就是艺术品。你必须明白这一点。薇薇安一直为自己非常精心制作服装而感到自豪。你在这里看到了一种非凡的工艺、关怀以及彻头彻尾的离经叛道的结合。这种离经叛道以至于其他店铺开始模仿薇薇安的设计。许多人都效仿了这些造型。一旦精灵逃出了神灯，国王路的整条街区
was selling variations upon a theme. There was loads to go with the punk loop. You know, you've got studying and wristbands and leather harness, you know, loads of ephemera that could add on to it. So it gave loads of people a chance to have a business. Punk was easy to rip off. Michael showed me some imitation bondage trousers that used to belong to his wife. They were made by another shop called Boy. These were copies, Boy copied all Vivian's things
都在售卖各种主题的变体。有很多元素可以与朋克风格相搭配。你知道，你有饰钉、腕带和皮革背带，你知道，有很多可以叠加的附加小物件。因此，这给很多人提供了一个做生意的机会。朋克很容易被抄袭。迈克尔给我看了一些曾属于他妻子的仿制束缚裤。它们是由另一家名为Boy的店铺制造的。这些都是复制品，Boy抄袭了薇薇安所有的设计
and did the much cheaper fabrics. Further down the King's Road, yeah. Which was kind of cool because it gave more people a chance to wear the clothes, Vivian's hated boy. And she said, oh, maybe I should set my shop on fire because they'd have to do the same. But the other side of this coin was that individuals could imitate these looks very easily as well and sort of elaborate on them.
并使用了便宜得多的面料。就在国王路的更深处，没错。这其实挺酷的，因为它让更多的人有机会穿上这些衣服，而薇薇安恨透了Boy。她说，哦，也许我应该把我的店铺放火烧了，因为这样他们就得跟着做同样的事了。但硬币的另一面是，个人也能非常容易地模仿这些造型，并在此基础上进行发挥。
You know tape and bandages and God knows what. Vivian had created a style lexicon that anyone could play around with. Lavatry chain, safe to pin, you know, it was a very do-it-yourself ethic. I mean, you could go into your own wardrobe right now, and rip stuff up and put it back together and make it punk. And that DIY part, that Vivian love. It gave a chance for the kids with no money to develop a do-it-yourself version of that. Vivian Westwood, after all, didn't have any training as a seamstress.
你知道，胶带、绷带以及天知道还有什么。薇薇安创造了一个任何人都可以随心所欲运用的风格词汇库。厕所链、安全别针，你知道，这是一种非常典型的DIY精神。我的意思是，你现在就可以走进自己的衣柜，把东西撕碎，再重新拼凑起来，把它变成朋克的。而那部分DIY精神，正是薇薇安所热爱的。它让那些没有钱的孩子有机会开发出属于他们自己的DIY版本。毕竟，薇薇安·韦斯特伍德并没有受过任何女红培训。
She just figured out how to do these things. So anyone could and should follow her lead. It was part of this shared movement of rebellion that these clothes could be adopted and customized and adapted by anybody wherever you came from. However, ritual poor you are, however old you were, whatever sexual you could take these clothes on and perhaps you might save up to buy a pair of
她只是自己琢磨出怎么做这些东西。所以任何人都可以也应该追随她的领导。这是这种共享的反叛运动的一部分，这些衣服可以被任何人采用、定制和改编，无论你来自哪里。无论你有多穷，无论你多大年纪，无论你的性取向如何，你都可以穿上这些衣服，也许你会存钱买一条
bondage trousers but you'd customise your own t-shirt. Punk became grassroots. As Vivian herself has said, it wasn't invented from the streets. It was the other way around. It turned into a movement. So I think in a way it was quite a sort of joyful explosion of taking possession of your own identity.
束缚裤，但你会自己定制T恤。朋克运动变得平民化了。正如薇薇安自己所说，它不是从街头发明的。事实恰恰相反。它演变成了一场运动。所以我认为在某种程度上，这是一种相当快乐的爆发，重新掌握了你自己的身份认同。
And before the internet, this look was cross-pollinated between New York and London by touring bands like the Sex Pistols and the Ramones. And so there started to be this back-and-forth dialogue a little bit between the two scenes, but they were visually really different. Monica Sklar, fashion historian and author of the book, Punk Style. She says the New York look was based in functionality. With New York being jeans, t-shirts, using safety pins for functional purposes.
在互联网出现之前，这种造型是通过像性手枪乐队（Sex Pistols）和雷蒙斯乐队（Ramones）这样巡回演出的乐队，在纽约和伦敦之间互相传播的。因此，这两个场景之间开始产生了一点来回的对话，但它们在视觉上有着巨大的不同。莫妮卡·斯克拉（Monica Sklar），时尚历史学家兼《朋克风格》一书的作者。她表示，纽约的造型基于实用性。纽约的风格是牛仔裤、T恤，为了实用目的而使用别针。
But the London look, thanks to Vivian Westwood, was rooted in art aesthetic. As bands toward and cultures mix, spheres of influence spread across the US. And then it would go around the country and around the globe. Other scenes would come to fruition and take on their own bed of influence. Depending on bands, on the weather, on the local culture, punk became reinterpreted.
但伦敦的造型，多亏了薇薇安·韦斯特伍德，根植于艺术美学。随着乐队四处巡演和文化的融合，影响力的范围扩散到了全美各地。然后它会传遍全国乃至全球。其他的亚文化场景将应运而生，并接受它们自己的一套影响力。根据乐队、天气以及当地文化的不同，朋克被重新诠释。
Whether it's San Diego, whether it's T.C., whether it's Detroit, London, New York, Minneapolis, had a large series of bands and style leaders. And then as those individuals and their stuff, whether it's them personally traveling around or as their zine makes those individuals, and their stuff, whether it's them personally traveling around or as their Z-makes that are around, or their music, they'll get to the next place. The style goes with them. Note how Monica's Glouare said their style went with them. Not their fashion.
无论是圣迭戈、双城、底特律、伦敦、纽约、明尼阿波利斯，都涌现出了一系列庞大的乐队和风格领袖。然后，随着这些个人以及他们的物品——无论是他们亲自四处旅行，还是通过他们的杂志让这些个人以及他们的物品四处传播，或者是他们的音乐——它们会到达下一个地方。风格随之而去。注意莫妮卡·斯克拉是怎么说的，他们的风格随他们而去。而不是他们的时尚。
This goes way beyond punk or subculture, but especially in the United States, fashion is associated with entire groups of people that are often relegated as secondary. Women, queers people of color and youth. Fashion is the realm of the historically powerless. And so people don't want to talk about things that are associated with them,
这远远超出了朋克或亚文化的范畴，但特别是在美国，时尚往往与一整群人联系在一起，而这些人通常被归为次要地位。女性、酷儿、有色人种和年轻人。时尚是历史上没有权力的人的领地。因此，人们不想谈论与他们相关的事情，
but they do have this huge awareness of style and how important style is. Style, according to sociologist Michael Breake, is a combination of three elements. Image. Image. So what are we looking at? Demeter.
但他们对风格以及风格的重要性有着巨大的意识。根据社会学家迈克尔·布雷克的说法，风格是三个要素的结合。形象。形象。所以我们在看什么？风度。
What's our attitude when we're wearing it? And this concept called Argo. Argo, this French concept of sling and secret language and secret coding. Kind of like jargon, special words or phrases that only insiders in a group would know. Altogether, it's that embodiment. And so being able to have image demeanor and Argo with authenticity is true punk style. In other words, it's part of what makes you authentic or a poser. If you have the right style.
我们穿上它时的态度是什么？以及这个叫做“黑话”（Argo）的概念。黑话，这个源自法语的概念，指的是俚语、秘密语言和秘密编码。有点像行话，只有群体的内部人员才知道的特殊词汇或短语。总的来说，这就是那种具象化。因此，能够将形象、风度和黑话与真实性结合起来，才是真正的朋克风格。换句话说，如果你拥有正确的风格，这就是让你成为真实的人还是一个冒牌货的一部分。
And for punks, it was this ceaseless hunt to sniff out true punk style. It was a lot of looking for little clues, hints of authenticity, trying to figure out who was on your side and who was a sell-out. It was constant, and it was exhausting. In fact, only shortly after its editionaries opened in the late 70s, Vivian Westwood herself got tired of it. In hindsight, she said, I got tired of looking at clothes from this point of view of rebellion. I found it exhausting. After a while, I wasn't sure if I was right. I'm sure that if there is such a thing as the anti-establishment, it feeds the establishment.
对于朋克来说，这是一场寻找真正朋克风格的无休止的搜寻。这需要寻找许多小线索、真实性的暗示，试图弄清楚谁站在你这一边，谁是个出卖原则的人。这是持续不断的，而且令人精疲力竭。事实上，就在其精品店于70年代末开业后不久，薇薇安·韦斯特伍德本人就对此感到厌倦了。事后回想起来，她说，我厌倦了从反叛的角度来看待服装。我发现这令人筋疲力尽。过了一会儿，我不确定自己是否是对的。我确信，如果真的存在反建制这种东西，它其实是在滋养建制。
And if you give something a label, then that's all it can be. And the whole thing about punk is it ever-evolving. And for some people, they got stuck on this early definition. It's about fast guitars. It's about Mohawk, say to me, and leather jackets. No man, that was just like one screaming shout that got you through the door. You weren't supposed to get stuck there. You know, you get on this ladder. You're smart. You keep climbing. Into the 80s, a lot of London punks kept climbing. Members of punk bands peeled off to learn how do you actually play their instruments and experiment experiment with like synthesizers. And interesting about post punk is all of a sudden people are kind of honest about what they really liked. And Vivian Westwood taught herself how to tailor, like gave herself a real formal training. So she embarked on this mission to self-educate
如果你给某样东西贴上标签，那么它就只能是那样东西了。而朋克的核心在于它一直在不断演变。对某些人来说，他们被困在了这个早期的定义里。它关乎快节奏的吉他。它关乎莫霍克发型、安全别针和皮夹克。不，伙计，那只是一声带你走进大门的尖叫。你本不该被困在那里。你知道，你踏上了这个阶梯。你很聪明。你继续往上爬。进入80年代，许多伦敦朋克继续往上爬。朋克乐队的成员们开始脱离出来，学习如何真正演奏他们的乐器，并尝试使用合成器。后朋克有趣的地方在于，突然之间，人们开始对他们真正喜欢的东西坦诚相待。薇薇安·韦斯特伍德自学了如何剪裁，这相当于给自己进行了一次真正的正规培训。于是她踏上了自我教育的使命，
herself through looking at 17th, 18th, 19th century dress. And this is not DIY, these are not garments that anyone could copy. Subsequent lines of Vivians played with corsetry, ball gowns, suits, even in clothes, using nicer materials and toying with elements of history, and even nostalgia. Stuff that was not punk. Punk closing was too dimensional. It could be laid flat. However, when she learns how to tailor, and this is a very difficult process that she taught herself, her clothes become more and more three-dimensional.
通过研究17、18、19世纪的服饰来充实自己。这不是DIY，这些不是任何人都能抄袭的服装。薇薇安随后的系列玩起了紧身胸衣、晚礼服、西装，甚至内衣，使用了更好的材料，并把玩了历史甚至怀旧的元素。这些东西可不是朋克。朋克服装是二维的。它们可以被平铺开来。然而，当她学会了剪裁——这是一个她自学的非常艰难的过程——她的服装变得越来越三维。
As her views of authority and establishment became multi-dimensional, her garments gained dimension as well. You see the development of her skill running alongside the development of her interest in history and also her not rejection of punk because I think it would always be part of her, but her moving on from always being on the defense, always being involved in some kind of conflict, political, sartorial conflict with the world. Do you sell things on Instagram, though? Yeah.
随着她对权威和建制的看法变得多维度，她的服装也随之获得了维度。你可以看到她的技能的发展与她对历史的兴趣的发展齐头并进，还有她对朋克的态度——不是拒绝，因为我认为朋克永远是她的一部分，而是她不再总是处于防御状态，不再总是卷入某种冲突中，与世界进行政治上、服饰上的冲突。不过你在Instagram上卖东西吗？对。
I was already... Oh, really? I've had... Instagram is like the wild west. It is very active. That store on 430 Kings Road. It still belongs to Westwood. Ever since 1980, it's been called World's End,
我已经……哦，真的吗？我有……Instagram就像狂野西部。它非常活跃。国王路430号的那家店。它仍然属于韦斯特伍德。自1980年以来，它被称为“世界尽头”，
and it has a giant clock on the front with its arm spinning backwards. And if you go there today, it's not really a band of misfits that hang out there anymore. But there are a lot of Japanese tourists who come to pilgrimage. Vivian Westwood is one of the most famous clothing designers in the world now. I mean, she's huge. She doesn't have the time to speak to me for this podcast. But she is the reason why I wanted to talk about clothing. Because in 2009, I heard her say this thing to the New York Times, and I haven't been
它的正面有一个巨大的时钟，时钟的指针在逆时针旋转。如果你今天去那里，那里已经不再是一群无所事事的边缘青年闲逛的地方了。但有很多日本游客前来朝圣。薇薇安·韦斯特伍德现在是世界上最著名的服装设计师之一。我的意思是，她太有名了。她没有时间接受我的采访来做这个播客。但她正是我想要谈论服装的原因。因为在2009年，我听到她对《纽约时报》说了这样一番话，自那以后我就一直
able to stop thinking about it since. The paradox is that people think that if they wear something simple and non-saying, that somehow they themselves will emerge all the more stunning and beautiful from it, it's not true, it might be true. No, not even true of Christi Tirlington. You know, no, no. I don't want to seek Christi Tirlington and her t-shirt and jeans. She can, why not if you're born, you know, somebody, a freak of beauty? Why not? You know, look like a goddess. Why not? I think everyone knows that feeling when you're dressed in an outfit you really like, and you look good, and you feel good.
无法停止思考。悖论在于，人们认为如果他们穿得简单而不引人注目，某种程度上他们自己就会从中显得格外惊艳和美丽，这不是真的，也许是真的。不，甚至对克里斯蒂·特灵顿（Christy Turlington）来说也不是真的。你知道，不，不。我不想看到克里斯蒂·特灵顿穿着她的T恤和牛仔裤。她当然可以，如果你天生就是一个美丽的美人怪胎，为什么不呢？你知道，看起来像个女神。为什么不呢？我想每个人都知道那种感觉，当你穿着一套你真的很喜欢的衣服时，你看起来很好，你也感觉很好。
That is an essential power of clothing, aside from covering your body or keeping you warm. It has the power to give you confidence. It's why Roman dresses up when he goes to do a live performance. I have lots of options and ties, and I have lots of options and pocket squares and stuff like that. And I have fun with that to perform and to actually show respect that I care about these things to an audience. That's what that signals to me. And I also like it, I think I look good. And the thing Punk did was push the boundaries of what looks good.
那是服装的基本力量，除了遮羞或保暖之外。它拥有赋予你自信的力量。这就是罗曼在进行现场表演时要盛装打扮的原因。我有很多选择和领带，我有很多选择和口袋巾之类。我通过这些来获得乐趣以进行表演，并且向观众真正表达我关心这些事情的尊重。这就是它对我所释放的信号。而且我也喜欢它，我觉得我看起来不错。而朋克所做的事情，是拓宽了什么才叫好看的边界。
It's not about looking perfect or clean or rich. It incorporated people of all ages and bodies and backgrounds and ideas and gave them that confidence. It pushed our ideas of beauty. And Professor Monica Sklar knows this first hand. Beauty standards were pushed and pushed and pushed. I was fired from a record store. A record store is a use for having an eyebrow piercing. And now I'm a professor and curator and vice president
它与看起来完美、干净或富有无关。它融合了所有年龄、身材、背景和思想的人，并赋予他们这种自信。它推动了我们的美学观念。教授莫妮卡·斯克拉对此有着切身体会。审美标准一次又一次地被推动。我曾被一家唱片店解雇。唱片店因为我有眉钉而解雇我。而现在我是一名教授、策展人和副会长，
of the National Society of my profession. And I have it. And really, this is the power of what fashion designers can do. Something that appears strange or scary or expensive at first can trickle down through the cycle of trends, and maybe, in time, come to expand notions of what's acceptable, so that more people can feel comfortable expressing their own style, their own cocktail of image, demeanor, and argo, however it manifests. And this myth that it's frivolous or unproductive to care about how you look or what you wear
服务于我所在行业的全国协会。我身上就有眉钉。真的，这就是时装设计师所能做的事情的力量。某种起初看起来奇怪、可怕或昂贵的东西，可以通过潮流的周期逐渐普及，也许在一段时间后，会扩大人们对什么是可以接受的观念，以便更多的人能够舒适地表达他们自己的风格，表达他们自己的形象、风度和黑话的鸡尾酒，无论它以何种形式表现出来。而这种认为关心自己外表或穿着是轻浮或没有产出的神话，
is completely bunk. To not have to think about how you present, or to assume that you can somehow dress in a way that is neutral or non-saying. That is a massive, massive privilege. Whether we like it or not, we are all speaking with our clothes. And we might as well give a good, hard think about what we want to say. The pocket, the piece of paper Words from yesterday There's a portrait painted on the things we love
完全是胡说八道。不必考虑你的外在呈现，或者认为你可以用一种中立的、不引人注目的方式穿衣。这是一种巨大无比的特权。不管我们喜欢与否，我们都在用我们的衣服说话。我们不妨好好认真思考一下我们到底想说些什么。口袋，一张纸 来自昨天的字眼 在我们所爱的事物上画有一幅肖像
A ring called with a hidden story Ring cold on this flight A spider like an ancient vessel, a language stolen by There's a picture printed on the face, we're alive A pocket, a piece of paper The pencil paper Words run yesterday There's a portrait painted on the things that we love Articles of Interest is made by myself, Avery Treffleman, with editing from Katie Mingle and Joe Rosenberg. Music by Rebecca Redmond, Shannon Bedroghe, Jenna Marx, and Maya Ossetto of the band Sore.
一枚带着隐藏故事的戒指 戒指在这趟航行中变冷 像一门古老的船只一样的蜘蛛，被……偷走的语言 脸庞上印刷着一张照片，我们还活着 口袋，一张纸 铅笔纸 昨天流淌的字眼 在我们所爱的事物上画有一幅肖像 《感兴趣的物品》由我自己Avery Treffleman制作，Katie Mingle和Joe Rosenberg参与剪辑。音乐由Sore乐队的Rebecca Redmond, Shannon Bedroghe, Jenna Marx和Maya Ossetto创作。
The theme songs for Articles of Interest are by Tzassami Ashworth. Fact check by Graham Haysha, mixed by Sheree Fusef, and Roman Mars is the Ian McKay of this whole series. Special thanks to Sonnet Stanfell, Ella Ravennalist, Brendan Cormier, and the online library Bloomsbury Fashion Central. Thanks as well to Marion McEun, Delaney Hall, Vivian Lee, Sean Rial, Kurt Colstet, and the whole 99PI team. There's a portrait of painting the things we love. The history of clothing is not a linear one.
《感兴趣的物品》的主题曲由Tzassami Ashworth创作。事实核查由Graham Haysha完成，混响由Sheree Fusef完成，Roman Mars是整个系列中的Ian McKay。特别感谢Sonnet Stanfell, Ella Ravennalist, Brendan Cormier以及在线图书馆Bloomsbury Fashion Central。同样感谢Marion McEun, Delaney Hall, Vivian Lee, Sean Rial, Kurt Colstet以及整个99PI团队。在我们所爱的事物上画一幅肖像。服装的历史并不是线性的。
It circles back around and around on itself. Styles weave in and out through the decades. Each time reincarnated in new materials with new associations. The history of clothing is a history of subversion, whether it's bringing bondage wear into the light of day, or jeans into the workplace, or pockets into women's wear. It's a dynamic that puts our bodies in conversation with all the many, many political, societal,
它不断地自我盘旋回绕。各种风格在几十年间交织穿梭。每一次都带着新的材料和新的联想在新的形态中转世。服装的历史是一部颠覆的历史，无论是将束缚装带入白日的光明中，还是将牛仔裤带入工作场所，或是将口袋带入女装中。这是一种动态过程，让我们的身体与所有那些在我们之前的时尚周期中决定了潮流的政治、社会、
and economic forces that have determined the fashions before us as the cycle of trends goes around, and around, and around. And that's it. That concludes articles of of Interest. Thank you for listening! And by the way, this gorgeous music box theme that you're listening to was composed by the great Sean Rial, our 99PI staff composer.
和经济力量进行对话，随着潮流的周期一圈又一圈地旋转。就是这样。这就结束了《感兴趣的物品》。感谢您的收听！顺便说一句，你正在听的这个华丽的八音盒主题曲是由伟大的Sean Rial创作的，他是我们的99PI员工作曲家。
And we're back to regular 99% invisible programming after this, and all these episodes will be archived on a separate feed. We're thinking about whether or not we want to do a second season of this. So let me know your thoughts. I'm on Twitter at Truffleman, 1F, and at Articles of Interest on Instagram. Oh, and a final thought. We're celebrating this podcast with a big clothing swap. And if you've never been to one of these before,
在听完这个之后，我们将回归常规的99% Invisible节目，所有这些剧集都将被存档在一个单独的源中。我们正在考虑是否要制作第二季。所以请让我知道你们的想法。我在Twitter上的账号是@Truffleman，1F，在Instagram上是@Articles of Interest。哦，还有一个最后的想法。我们正在通过一场盛大的旧衣交换活动来庆祝这个播客。如果你以前从来没参加过这种活动的话，
it's where a bunch of people gather somewhere and everyone brings their clothes that they don't want anymore, and then trade them all up with each other for free. I find it's the most sustainable and most interesting way to dress. Consider throwing a clothing swap of your own sometime, because you have to wear clothes anyway, right? Radio Topeon from PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那就是一大群人聚集在某处，每个人都把自己不想要的衣服带来，然后大家互相免费交换。我发现这是最可持续、最有趣的穿衣方式。考虑什么时候自己也办一场旧衣交换活动吧，因为不管怎样你总是得穿衣服的，对吧？来自PRX的Radio Topeon。这一集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。